hi this is presh talwalkar i'm going to
teach you how you can multiply numbers
by drawing lines let's say you want to
multiply 12 by 13.
for the one we'll draw one line and then
for the two we'll leave some space and
draw two lines for the other number
we'll draw lines in the opposite
direction
now we will group intersections that are
vertically aligned and count the number
of intersections in each group
there are six intersections on the right
five in the center and 1 on the left
we can combine these numbers to get to
our answer of 156
we can use this technique even for
larger numbers
for 123 times 321
we use exactly the same process of
drawing lines for each digit of the
number
for the other number we will draw lines
in the opposite direction making sure to
leave space between the lines for each
digit
now we will group intersections that are
vertically aligned and then count the
number of intersections in each group
the center group has a lot of
intersections we want to count them
carefully they're fourteen
before we get to the answer we have to
make one adjustment we need to carry the
one of the fourteen over to the eight
and eight plus one makes nine
now we have our answer of thirty nine
thousand four hundred and eighty three
you can also multiply numbers by drawing
lines for numbers that include a digit
zero
we'll simply draw
the line for zero in a different color
if you don't have a different color
you can use a dashed line just to know
that the zero line is different
after we group vertically aligned
intersections we count the number of
intersections in each group
but we make one adjustment we don't
count any of the intersections with the
zero line because zero times anything is
zero
and that gets us to our answer of twenty
two thousand seven hundred and sixty
three we can also do polynomial
expressions x plus two times x plus
three
we will draw the lines for x in a
different color
now we group the vertically aligned
intersections on the far right there are
six between
unit lines in the middle there are five
between a red and a black line which
makes it 5x
an intersection of two red lines is an x
squared
which gets us our answer of x squared
plus five x plus six
please subscribe to my channel i make
videos on math and game theory you can
support me on patreon catch me on my
blog mind your decisions on twitter at
preshtalwalker and you can get please
get my book on multiplying numbers by
drawing lines